edith is with us in houston texas hi
edith welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so my question is last
March my husband and I purchased a
tractor and we paid twenty six thousand
for it and of that two thousand was for
insurance and it was insurance straight
through Kubota so we are new listeners
and we're down to or less our last debt
but we're not we're not sure what to do
because when I try to make the last
payment they told me that I'd be kind of
downgrading on my insurance and that I'd
have to get either a second policy
through them or through insurance are we
talking about just tractor insurance so
to replace it or to fix it he repairs
anything that happens to it oh you
bought an extended warranty they didn't
say was a warranty they said it was
insurance well that's repairs okay it's
not it's not if the tractor gets stolen
you have insurance through your
homeowners or your farm operation for
the tractor gets stolen right so the
tractor is that not at my house it's at
my mom's property that doesn't matter
you bought insurance from your insurance
agent on the tractor being stolen didn't
you yes but my insurance will be voided
if I pay off the loan early and what
they're telling me one more time did you
call your insurance agent and buy
insurance on your tractor in case it
gets stolen no I'm not through Allstate
no I bought it through the tractor
cancel the crap with Kubota and pay the
people at Kubota off they've combined
some kind of bogus extended warranty
with some kind of coverage and I'm not
sure you even have theft insurance on
your tractor they said I do they said
that the only difference would be that
if if it they said that if anything
happens to it I lose out on Ratana
replacement
factor that they would be able to
replace it they are awfully refer you to
keep this insurance and stay in debt to
them aren't they yeah I feel weird yeah
you need to get on I mean do you guys
have a farm operation or is this John
like a gentleman farmer torn tractor no
it's just a um it's for my mom's
property I was helping her clear the
property and yeah okay so it's a
gentleman farmer operation at most we're
not really doing this as a business okay
no not at all call go online at Dave
Ramsey comm and click on insurance and
price your car and your homeowners with
an independent insurance agent and price
tractor insurance and pay Kubota off and
tell them to jump in the creek okay
because you're getting ripped off okay
okay you got ripped off at the purchase
you paid way too much for this insurance
because they rolled it and they combined
it together with basically what is an
extended warranty on the tractor the
director already had some warranties and
if it's a brand-new Kubota tractor they
actually make a very good tractor and so
if it's a brand-new Kubota tractor you
probably had almost no trouble with it
and likely won't they're very reliable
so no you do not buy insurance from the
manufacturer on your tractor and you
definitely don't stay in debt in order
to keep the insurance cancel the whole
thing get debt-free as soon as you get
insurance on your tractor for theft and
you self insure through the repairs that
the standard Kubota warranty does not
cover which is not a bad warranty either
if you bought a brand-new tractor which
by the way you should not have done for
a gentleman farmer operation publishing
the dunnock period but you should have
bought a tractor for about half that
much money that would have done the
exact job used and it wouldn't have gone
down in value so quickly so side issue
but you know we're there now so pay the
thing off get clear get you basic
insurance in place with a good property
and casualty
agent who can shop among several
different companies they're called an
insurance broker and they'll put good
insurance on your tractor so that if it
gets stolen or there's a fire and it
burned or something like that just like
your car just like buying car insurance
think about it this way if you bought a
new car from Ford and they covered your
car and it cost about five times more
for the insurance then you could have
bought the insurance from an insurance
broker for but it includes all this
extra stuff that it covers in case the
car breaks down what did you buy you
bought an extended warranty bundled with
an expensive car insurance policy from
Ford that's what you bought and that's
exactly what we're talking about here
that's what Kubota did I didn't even
know they did that but that's what
they've done here anytime these
insurance companies start bundling stuff
together you can pretty well figure out
they're getting ready to screw you
there's one exception to that and that
is if you buy your car and your
homeowners insurance at the same place
oftentimes you can get a discount on
that but other than that if they start
trying to sell you long-term care
insurance for a nursing home but it
includes life insurance and danger Will
Robinson are getting ready to get
screwed okay every time they put stuff
together in the insurance world it is
for their benefit in their profit and
these companies are selling extended
warranties on their products make more
money on the extended warranty than they
do margin on the product a lot of times
so that's why when you can't go in Best
Buy you can't buy install at Best Buy
without getting an extended warranty
offer on it I'm amazed at what you can
get an extended warranty on I mean a bit
lighter they will give you an extended
warranty on it it's it's it's crazy but
they figured out where their money is
Best Buy doesn't have much margin in
those TVs it's really a really good buy
on the TV it is a Best Buy they're not
kidding I mean it's a pair of a really
fair price when you're going there by
the TV but try getting out there with
about borrowing money or buying an
extended warranty you look down there's
a Salesman hanging on your leg while
you're trying to get in the car it's
ridiculous they wear you out trying to
sell you a credit card or extended
warranty you can't get
in a Victoria's Secret with underwear
without somebody trying to sell you a
credit card because they pay them more
for selling credit cards than it is
selling underwear it's the same thing
they know where their money is made and
you just got it look if they if they're
giving you this much grief about it it's
because they make money on it it's that
simple
they wear your butt out you know you
just but they make a ton on this stuff
the credit card I mean you get 10% off
it Macy's oh my god 10% off so you can
make five thousand percent on me for the
rest of your life and a chokehold all
because it got a pair of socks at your
place oh my gosh but that's exactly
figured out where their money is they
make more money on extended warranties
and on cart offering credit on this
stuff than they do and now insurance
will add to the list with the with the
old Kubota tractor here Wow who knew but
that's that's the way it is same things
true the car they're going extended
warranty so where your butt out and they
make up run on it especially I only use
car extended warranty